this is an example of a video i launched  a month ago the slides a couple days old  in one month  we made this video we put it live on  youtube it now has almost 160 thousand  views  it has what two thousand thumbs ups two  hundred plus comments  i did zero advertising for this zero  advertising  it took off because it's a really good  campaign  you watch this video and for those of  you who are sitting on my thursday  session i'm gonna be playing this video  live you watch this video and you feel  something  and that makes you wanna share it your  campaigns have to be  this good they have to be something that  when people see it  they want to share it i could throw  advertising dollars on top of this  and make it explode but it's already  trending pretty well right now  you